hey uh real quick let me ask you do
who's your top five favorite rappers uh
controversial question no i usually
narrow it to a three but i could go five
um so at the the pinnacle you know and
it could go in any order for me but
realistically it should be krs-1 at the
top for me
um eminem
jay-z
rock kim
um coogie wrap
and uh you know i did i did a track with
cool g rap
one of the sickest in the world man and
stevo yeah
he said well i'm not gonna say you're
the next jay-z
oh my god yeah that's great so those
yeah those are my guys right there man
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude